hello and welcome to this video yeah
this video is done to celebrate the
release of my new keep it simple 1.d4
course on chesil and in order to
celebrate probably we are doing a
giveaway and it is only got one price
but it is a pretty nice one and you will
win one month of coaching with me if you
turn out to be the winner yeah so one
month of coaching means eight sessions
two per week I mean this is rather
flexible but yeah you get to get the
idea it will be um certainly more than
ten hours off of lessons and people can
discuss any topic on chess that you like
a training plan for you some specific
opening questions discuss your games
whatever you like and whatever you think
is the most most fun or the most
rewarding we'll see what happens okay so
how can you actually win this it's easy
you have to go into the page here for
the contest and that is reached by going
to chasuble calm slash free coaching
it's um in the video below now go to
that page and you're arrived exactly
where amia already and you have to login
down you can use some something that you
already have like Facebook or Twitter or
use a mail I'm going to do Facebook here
because that is working because I don't
have to enter anything here at the
moment now this is the actual contest
page where you need to do something um
the thing is you have you have multiple
possible entries that you can make and
the more entries you make the better
chances you have to win you can just
leave it like that and that you can't
one entry already um but you can
basically increase your chances by
multiple times if you have multiple
entries and this is easy to do for
example you have a couple of things that
you can do that Nets you an extra entry
like maybe for example you can click on
this visit chasuble on youtube and then
you would visit the page and you get to
the Chesterville YouTube page
this already netted to me an extra entry
so I've doubled the chances to win my
own price well okay I will of course
delete that later but then this is the
idea behind it you so you can do
multiple things that you get additional
entry points the ones that are most
valuable arm the two on the on the
bottom here um this one let me click on
that one
that gets you to the page the videos
right on my my this
I love anyway so you'll get you'll get a
free video here one hour and one hour
video extract of the keep it simple 1.d4
course it is completely completely free
and we'll show you a nice way to fight a
certain opening within the 1.d4 universe
so this is a nice freebie that you can
that you can use now going back here um
you can also click on the one on the
bottom and this is the one that gives
you the most points five points and if
you do that okay
I do understand hey it's not it's not
it's not yet public but now now we're
here and this is the the starting pace
the course page here for keep it simple
one deform where you can when it is
released like a very shortly not not at
the time of the recording where you can
buy the course also now um it gets a
nice overview here of what a little bit
of a story about the course and some
information and you should read it a
little bit because in order to get to
five points going back here you will
also need to answer a simple relatively
simple question IAM about the course
content and that gives you five
additional points and if you get all the
points you have really lots did you give
increase the chances a lot to to win you
don't need to click anywhere to submit
it now once you are on that page you can
you can also do that like on two or
three days in succession and get the
points there you can do it the whole
time as long as the contest is live and
it's always be submitted real time
there's no submit button or anything so
i currently would be able to have five
entries and have some chances to win my
own price which would be kind of funky I
didn't do it we won one month of
coaching with myself
maybe that will net something anyway I
hope you enjoyed this little video and I
hope that you will enter the competition
the contest it's a search
going to be fun if you win I had a
similar competition for keeping sample
1e keep it simple one year for and that
was just one lesson yeah and it was lots
of fun so I hope hope you win keep
fingers crossed and thanks for watching
this little video bye-bye